[Music]
first loves and SIL together never been
with anybody else your entire lives it's
so crazy our sex life is really really
great he's quick compared to what into a
viewers so perfect and constant and
inevitable and boring jus curious you
must be sorry about race last night you
know it's not like I feel like I'm
missing out am i holding you back I know
how much you love me and you say what
you mean I think that you should sleep
with other women I don't think it's
gonna work oh why not
I could be you free tonight that's great
human nature
thousands of cautionary tales preceding
you you smell like my father that's not
us
you want to be with Reese forever no I
would like to be with Reese for as long
as we make each other happy
[Music]
so you have secrets tell me what is it
smelling bad
did you do everything a lot of things
is he better it was different different
better different different you're still
attracted to will right yes
sex is sex but that's what you agreed to
just be careful you just think that you
meet the one but you can't just be one
[Music]
you